[Musik]
3d drucker sind eine absolute revolution
und wir haben gerade erst begonnen zu
begreifen welche türen dass der menschen
öffnet in der industrie in der medizin
und sogar euer ganzes zu hause können
sie mittlerweile mit einem 3d beton
drucker gedruckt werden
ich persönlich habe in 3d sogar schon
versucht dem spielzeug zu erfinden hast
du dir selbst konzipiert nehmen dass so
ein eigenes instrument gebaut und im
stromgenerator gebaut der per handkurbel
funktionieren kann man auch einen ganzen
gaming pc im 3d drucker machen so
richtig nah es mit klaren durchsichtigen
fenster und das halt im 3d drucker dass
wir jetzt diese woche heraus und ich
habe genau sieben tage zeit das ganze
projekt muss natürlich ein pc geplant
und modelliert werden bevor es später in
den 3d drucker geht und das mache ich
mit dem absoluten wies das mir einfach
niemand geringerer als nvidia und
mitkommen zugeschickt haben von denen
auch dieses video gesponsert wird und
das ist gleich doppelt praktisch weil
zum einen kommt man aktuelle pc langsam
nicht mehr mit dem ganzen verrückten
kran mit den ich hier in diesen videos
mache und die felix und ich dann
zusätzlich auch noch meistens in 4k
raushauen und zum anderen a
dazu kommen wir gleich mein neue pc ist
jetzt also ein high end ein videostudio
pc von mit kommt mit einer nvidia 3090
rtx 64 gb arbeitsspeicher dem reisen 95
1950 x-raid dicken 16 kernen und
natürlich perfekt abgestimmten er
gewählt als klar was genau uns das jetzt
alles ermöglicht werden wir später sehen
und nein minecraft mit zweieinhalb
tausend apps zu spielen ist noch nicht
mal das coolste kommen wir arbeiten mit
dem pc den wir diese woche selbst bauen
werden nennen wir sie mal dampfmaschine
ich habe dafür echt schon richtig viele
wirkte ideen- sie soll vor allem im
steampunk stil sein das ist der stil den
er gerade hier so in diesen bildern
vermittelt bekommt ja und sie sollte
einen in sich zusammen hängen denn
mechanismus mit zahnrädern und dies und
das haben das ganze soll sich über
elektronik die wir später löten werden
auch noch richtig bewegen aber bevor wir
das dann alles design am pc brauche ich
natürlich noch die maße der einzelnen
komponenten die wir
rein verbauen ja und dafür schlage ich
jetzt die teil auswahl heraus die dann
in unsere mechanischen monstrum verbaut
werden und dann dadurch weiter leben
dürfen sie nicht hin euro pc bis zum
jugend die teile die wir jetzt hier mit
allergrößter vorsicht hier ausprobieren
werden
die sind natürlich nicht mehr der
allerneuesten stand aber trotzdem werde
mich jetzt einige kassen wenn das nur
noch 1 2 pc ist nvidia rtx 2080
[Applaus]
schon jetzt ganz vorsichtig die
wasserkühlung das motherboard inklusive
prozessor intel die 9100 k und ein
bisschen arbeitsspeicher jedoch ein
netzteil das ding hier hat ausgedient so
und genau das das ganze zeug was da
jetzt rein kommt muss natürlich jetzt
messen war der rbl wenn ich jetzt keinen
speziellen grund war und die ganze
technik kann einfach nicht reinpassen
dieses teil das muss natürlich exakt
genau ausgemessen werden wo jetzt zum
beispiel diese anteile sitzen wo jetzt
der prozessor setzt das muss jetzt nicht
haargenau seien aber macht natürlich
trotzdem halbwegs glaube ich erstelle
direkt nebenbei jetzt hier läuft das ab
märz das 3d modell von dem ding das ich
dann später zusammenbauen kann
ja genau auf diese art und weise muss
ich daher zeit jedes einzelne teil
gruppe nach modellierten viel spaß mir
auch gehen wir selber
die kirche ist wahrscheinlich auch
geschieht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so habe ich jetzt mal alle komponenten
angeordneten sie dann in der
dampfmaschine sein sollen ist ein sehr
sehr kuriose setup und darum drum herum
kommen jetzt unseren pc bauen wir jetzt
alles das ganze gerüst bauen und
natürlich auch die ganzen details und
das ist wie gesagt der spannende partie
dafür habe ich jetzt erstmal viel zu
lange braucht ich habe jetzt ich habe
zwei tage gebraucht um die ganzen
komponenten nach zu modellieren manche
sachen sie nur recht groß manche stellen
musste ich relativ detailliert machen
damit ich quasi diese schrauben und so
auch eins zu eins in unseren häusern
modellieren kann mit vorwärts mit dem
ganzen fans sie zeigt anfangen fangen
erst an mit einem grundgerüst also dass
er prinzipiell erst mal halbwegs
rechteckig und ich würde sagen dass wir
dafür mal ein rechteckiges grundgerüst
machen das schön stabil und dick ist an
dem wir festigen damit den rest hätte
ist das gehäuse ab damit in den 3d
drucker 23 stunden nur für das eine teil
okay wenn ich das diese woche noch
fertig haben will dann muss ich mir was
einfallen lassen ich muss mich schützen
hier aus holz machen die man ähnlich
sieht das wird sonst aber wochen dauern
es geht darum sich selbst einen kleinen
pc zu design mit dem 3d drucker und
nicht einfach das leben unnötig schwer
zu machen für teile die man ähnlich
sieht und die man einfach mal eben
zusammen nagel kann da ich mich aber
echte anhalten muss habe ich felix
gefragt ob er schon mal los diesen kann
um die holzteile vom baumarkt zu
besorgen während ich bereits das erste
teil für den 3d drucker gestaltet damit
dieser drucken kann während ich weiter
arbeiten und keinen leerlauf entsteht
fertig ist also die rückseite des pcs
mit passgenauen und leicht verstärkten
aussparungen für den lüfter den
anschlüssen am motherboard und der
grafikkarte und ein fenster für
luftschlitze die später separat in einer
anderen farbe gedruckt werden für mehr
kontrast apropos farbe aktuell ist das
ganze aber auch relativ grau aber wir
werden natürlich das ganze in super
neuesten kupfer filament oder gold war
mein silber oder sogar in so einem top
secret durchsichtigem glas filament
drucken aber jetzt mal herauszufinden
was die beste material bzw farbcodes die
rag mal die power meine neuen quelle
workstation von nvidia und mitkommen
nutzen um das ganze in kostenlosen
programm blender mit ziemlich
realistische materialien zur ändern
an holzschnitten am see irgendwo muss
der pc stehen damit quasi das fundament
das wir vor allem modelliert haben hier
die ganzen stützen ich jetzt mal
nacheinander aktivieren wir sind ja
direkt quasi das material einmal gründer
und wie diese schatten wieder wie
schnell das auch einfach geht das ist
echt komplett geisteskrank dass es fast
in echtzeit also es gibt kaum ränder
zeiten hier also ultra nützlich um uns
eine kleine vorschau zu geben meinte
meinen ganzen pc komponenten an
die werde ich jetzt nicht jeweils 16 uhr
ihren das habe ich einfach mattschwarz
gemacht die meisten bauteile sind
ungefähr in mattschwarz und ich bin mir
mal reinschauen ich hab die sache jetzt
auch nicht genau modelliert aber das
reicht auf jeden fall um unseren
eindruck zu geben wie die sagen dann
später aussehen werden wichtiger ist das
ist natürlich jetzt unser 3d gedruckt
haben einmal quasi diese rückseite schon
nicht vor allem modelliert hat aktuell
noch recht langweilig da kann man ganz
easy malen material auf klatschen zum
beispiel fangen mal mit silber
angriffsspiel und glänzten das würde
dann ungefähr so aussehen wenn ich
eigentlich recht leisten kann das ganze
mal kurz auf gold ändern wenn ich auch
neues gold machen wir die verzierungen
die seite hier will ich sagen machen so
stahlgrau übrigens mega spanner feld ich
kann das ganze hier einfach in echtzeit
bearbeiten während das richtig gut wenn
das ist normal wenn man modelliert sich
das ganze so aushalte relativ langweilig
dann nehmen wir also hier das
infomaterial und werfen den ready to
kann ich sie ja gerade das dauert 13
stunden
die meisten großen bauteile werde ich
übrigens wie hier zum drucken halbieren
müssen weil sie sonst einfach zu groß
für den drucker sind so felix war beim
baumarkt zugegebenermaßen aber schon
gestern morgen das hat alles viel länger
gedauert als ich dachte an sich übrigens
zum ersten mal auf den hauptkanal hier
an der neuen werkbank und da geht es
direkt los
hier eine liste mit längen die wir jetzt
hier ablegen müssen damit ich sagen
letztlich auf
[Musik]
am besten
alle teile sind fertig mache ich noch
nicht ganz die müssen nämlich jetzt hier
noch schön angebracht werden da unsere
rückseite bald fertig gedruckt sein wird
mache ich mich direkt ans nächste
bauteil für den 3d drucker die rechte
seite ich modell ihre sie relativ
schlicht mit einer großen verstärkten
aussparung für die wasserkühlung die zum
teil außen sichtbar sein soll sowie vier
luftschlitzen und ringsherum angedeutet
hätten nur für die optik beim material
entscheide ich mich hier wieder in 3d
echtzeit rendering dafür dass diese
seite ebenfalls silber werden soll der
3d druck dauert nun für beide hälften
insgesamt elf stunden weswegen es echt
praktisch ist schon im vorfeld zu wissen
wie es hinterher aussehen wird sonst
wird man vielleicht das falsche material
und muss es neu drucken sowas häuser
sind jetzt alle teile fertig und sogar
ziemlich genau von den maßen her
jetzt geht's an zusammenbauen ich bin ja
mal gespannt ob das ding am ende
überhaupt angehen und funktioniert
[Musik]
dass meine zeit ist in 3d drucker und
hier hatte ich schon mal die fertige
rückseite finde ich richtig geil
geworden obwohl ich die
druckeinstellungen jetzt so gemacht
haben können das auch gleich mal hier
rein halten kommen dann einmal hierhin
aber ich würde sagen bevor wir das fest
machen warum erstmals ganzen leben da
rein
[Musik]
das für mich wichtigste an steampunk
sind mitunter aber auch die mechanismen
und zahnräder damit sich etwas bewegt
davon werden also einige verschiedene
designt und anschließend über nacht
gedruckt
[Musik]
also und der ersten zahnräder außen
paradis druck sind fertig und ich war
sagen die sind richtig gut aus ich habe
am anfang befürchtet dass sie nicht
genug lenzen könnten dass er nicht genug
diesen kupfer bronze effekt rüberbringen
können aber das tun die sowas von geil
die spiegeln und glänzen richtig neu ist
der andere frage ist natürlich jetzt
noch auf dieses planet getriebe dass ich
ja gestaltet habe auch wirklich
funktioniert ob das hinhaut ob das von
den abständen verpasst den ball knapp
okay aber für uns ist das ganze für
richtig geil und das sieht uli kraneis
aus und ich glaube dass das tool kann es
aussehen wenn das dann später einfach
mehr oder weniger unseren pc antreibt ja
so als getriebener
diese ganze woche ist ein wirrwarr
zwischen komponenten messen konzipieren
3d modellieren 3d druck staaten und
aufbereiten und handwerk und jetzt wird
mir schlagartig derzeit geplant meinte
was er das ganze innerhalb von einer
woche fällt zu machen und das stellt
sich gerade als extrem schwierig heraus
die woche ist in zwölf stunden vorbei
und ich muss noch ungefähr zwanzig
stunden 3d drucken
das ist zeitlich jetzt auch einfach
schon so das ist nicht gar nicht mehr
dieses druck bett hier sauber macht dass
man eigentlich jedes mal in diesem jahr
hier clinton über die ganze geschichte
kommt mir dann auch direkt das nächste
druck ich habe jetzt ist vorletzte teil
also den deckel des pcs nicht 1,5
millimeter was ihr schon dünne sondern
0,8 mm dick eingestellt und ich habe die
druckgeschwindigkeit jetzt von 60 mm pro
sekunde auf 120 verdoppelt und da kann
eigentlich nur hoffen dass das
funktioniert wenn das so stimmt ganz
hinhauen allerdings ist es durch die
hohe druckgeschwindigkeit auch extrem
wahrscheinlich dass ich mich jetzt für
die drei stunden druck zeit hinlegen um
mir meinen schlaf zu wenig dringend
brauche und wenn ich aufwachen den
kaputten druck sehr einfach nur zeit
verschwendet hat
das dach der konstruktion hat ein loch
und das soll nun mit einer glaskuppel
geschlossen werden dafür habe ich ein
besonderes material zum drucken und ein
besonderes druckverfahren in dem der
drucker in einem zug und nur eine
schichtdicke durchgängig druckt ob das
funktioniert nicht so funktioniere aber
was cool ist das einen kurzen halt
kratzen kann obwohl es nur eine ebene
tätig ist
das ist super cool ich wäre jetzt mal
probieren ob dieses ganze material
wirklich mit diesem alkohol hier extrem
glätten kann weil das soll man schon mal
mit dem material machen können und diese
typischen 3d drucker entfernen zu können
ich sprühe das was von dem dach über
geblieben ist also mit einem speziellen
alkohol ein und hoffe darauf dass dieses
so durchsichtig wird wie glas
sid jetzt letztendlich so aus also von
durchsichtigkeit ja an sich schon ganz
krass eigentlich allerdings die
oberfläche nicht wirklich schön nicht
wirklich eben und unreinheiten drauf und
damit ist eigentlich klar dass das jetzt
innerhalb von sieben tagen nichts
geworden ist wird also noch eine ganze
weile dauern bis das ding fertig
zusammengebaut ist und bis wir
herausfinden ob das teil am ende
überhaupt funktioniert eine woche später
mittlerweile sind fast alle teile
gedruckt die rechte seite die
vorderseite und alle anderen seiten auch
aber natürlich gibt es nicht nur diese
außenkanten sondern auch viele kleine
teile die erst so richtig leben
reinbringen werden wie diese branchen
denn zahnräder die in verschiedensten
arten kombiniert werden können aber auch
diese goldenen hier alle diese teile
sind so designt dass sie an irgendeiner
stelle in die außen platten passen wie
zum beispiel diese lüftungsgitter oder
die frontplatte für den einschaltknopf
und einigen anderen anschlüssen so sitzt
der zusammengebaute pc nun in 3d aus in
echtzeit rendering auf meinem neuen
nvidia studio pc von midcom ich finde es
besonders cool wie die goldenen und
bronson teile hier zur geltung kommen
und sich in den stählernen außen platten
spiegeln die einzige schwierigkeit wird
jetzt noch diese glaskuppel sein die
sich gerade zum zweiten und hoffentlich
letzten mal im 3d druck befindet und
besonders gespannt bin ich auch noch ob
das mit den zahnrädern wirklich so
funktioniert wie geplant
das ist der aktuelle stand ja da fehlt
noch viel ich bin mal gespannt ob ich so
zusammengebaut kriegen wir es gerade in
3d brille ring gesehen haben erzählt die
montage losgehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann ist das ding an und für sich schon
fällig gutgetan räder und leds und sie
waren sofort das sehen wir das spiel
jetzt ist erst mal wichtig er läuft das
teil oder gut gemacht es ging auch nicht
in die luft jetzt wird der knopf
betätigt und dann deutschland gehen ja
okay ich hab's nicht kaputt gemacht dass
gut es läuft ja wie gut es läuft und
auch wie gute sätze im vergleich zum
neuen pc abschneidet liegt guten
dampfmaschine
das findet natürlich später raus aber
ich habe es schon mal nicht kaputt
gemacht
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der pc sieht richtig
richtig nass aus dass hier oben nicht
nur immer ein bisschen weil glaskuppel
ja diesen bisschen gesungen hat aber
besser als der erste prototyp immerhin
vorne und hinten gibt es noch zwei
eröffnen wo man reingreifen kann falls
man ihn wäre noch was ändern will
okay noch einen strohmann also irgendwas
ein bisschen noch mal da ist doch clean
ja und wie ihr gesehen habt die
zahnräder die gene die lüfter haben
einfach nicht genug power um die dinge
anzudrehen mega schade aber die
mechanismen die müsste ich nochmal
komplett neu machen wohin das auge
schaut
das heißt wir können das teilt jetzt
einfach das ganze mal ein pc nutzen
richtig weh einmal dampf möchten wird
das ist richtig fand das ist für sie
wirklich komisch anlegen was kompliziert
zu sehen wie man dazu gewonnen ist nur
mit dem teil ja wohl einfach läuft hier
richtig schöne ja auch mit shader sogar
also ja man kann den pc mit dem 3d
drucker bauen das geht das heißt wir
können uns jetzt auf einer dampfmaschine
mit einem hohen preis
und ich würde sagen hier wird dann die
eine oder andere lernen heute damit
abgehalten werden ich kann das ergebnis
zum echten mega cool weil das war
wirklich das stressigste überhaupt liest
jetzt zwei wochen lang dran ist es
gerade sieben uhr morgens sie hat die
nacht durchgemacht
das ist immer noch nicht ganz fertig m10
kriege ich das also nicht so richtig
einen pc mit 3d drucker zu machen was
ich aber empfehlen kann sind die ein
video studio pcs von miss kommen die ihr
über den link in der beschreibung finden
können die kommen nämlich kaum dann
fällig bei euch an und sie bereite ich
auch kein ärger alle rechner können beim
ipcom auch komplett individuell
konfiguriert werden wenn er einen seht
ihr euch gefällt könnt ihr also zum
beispiel sagen hey mir würde auch ein
schlichteres gehäuse erreichen für das
filmmaterial beim schneiden braucht man
vielleicht eine zweite festplatte und
wenn er viel mit musik machen wollte
vielleicht noch eine extra soundkarte
das ganze wird dann fertig
zusammengebaut bei euch angeliefert und
support und garantie gibt's natürlich
auch die erste grafikkarte das habt ihr
zum beispiel bei diesen echtzeit
rendering es gesehen aber auch beim
prozessor lästigen aufgaben wie zum
beispiel beim videoschnitt ist das ein
extremer unterschied ist ein typisches
tommy 4k videos das vorher immer so 15
bis 20 mio
wenn unser könig minuten durch jeder
nvidia studio pc kommt übrigens auch mit
den speziellen nvidia studio treibern
die perfekt auf kreative anwendungen
zugeschnitten sind wie zum beispiel
blender cinema 4d und adobe programme
damit ist es aber allemal genug aber
denn ich bin jetzt wahrscheinlich erst
mal eine runde lag frei ist halber punk
oder minecraft zweieinhalbtausend fps
warum richten und damit verabschiede ich
mich wenn ihr das nächste video auch
nicht verpassen möchte belegt einen
kanal da kommt nächste woche wieder ein
video und dann sehen wir weiter
[Musik]